-Here´s what people are
talking about this morning.
President Trump went on
a Twitter rant about fake news
and threatened to revoke
NBC´s broadcast license.
[ Laughter ]
Americans are like, "Hey,
you can threaten our democracy,
but you do not mess with
"This Is Us."
I mean this..."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then later in the day,
Trump said it´s disgusting
that the press is able to write
whatever it wants to write.
[ Laughter ]
When asked about the first
amendment, he said,
"Is that the one that says not
to talk about fight club?
Because I know that one.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I also know the second one."
And everybody´s
talking about this.
Last night at the B.E.T. awards,
Eminem did a four-minute
freestyle rap criticizing Trump.
Of course, the president
isn´t just going
to ignore something like that.
So today, Trump clapped back
with a freestyle rap of his own.
[ Laughter ]
It´s a clapback.
Check this out.
-♫ Boom, boom ♫
♫ Boom, boom, knock, knock ♫
♫ Aaah, wah ♫
♫ Bum, bum, bum, China ♫
♫ B-b-b-b-bing that ♫
♫ Bomb, bomb, aah ♫
♫ Bing, bing, bum, bum, bum ♫
Hello!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello!
Hello!
[ Applause ]
-I mean, Trump was mad.
-Was he really?
-Trump was mad, but he
was also a little confused.
Today he told people to boycott
the M&M store.
-Are you serious?
-And you go, "No. That´s..."
-"Reese´s pieces are the best.
[ Laughter ]
They should have
their own store."
Meanwhile, attorney general
Jeff Sessions has been trying
to crack down on marijuana use
across the country,
and Obama´s former attorney
general said it´s basically
an obsession for him.
Yeah, check out what Sessions
had to say about it.
He said, "My position is that
marijuana should not be legal
anywhere in the United States
of America.
Blaa."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
Wow.
-What?
-Guys, I read that Kim Jong-un
wants to make the site
of his missile launches
a tourist destination
for families.
But for kids to go on the rides,
they must be taller
than Kim Jong-un.
-Really?
-Yeah, they have to.
[ Applause ]
It´s the only thing
they´re asking.
Big sports story here.
U.S. men´s soccer team
failed to qualify
for the World Cup
after losing to Trinidad
and Tobago last night.
In response, Trump was like,
"Why did America have to play
two countries at the same time?
Rigged.
That´s tough. Believe me."
[ Applause ]
Check this out.
Amazon just announced
that teens can now shop
on their parents´ accounts,
but the order
will only go through
if mom and dad approve it
or if they click the button
that says,
mom and dad approve it.
[ Laughter ]
-Click.
-I´ll wait for dad to see
if he can click this button.
Amazon´s also working
with a company to deliver items
to the trunk of your car.
[ Light laughter ]
The company has a very
interesting name -- The Mafia.
Very interesting, yeah.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.